This story really spoke to me.
The Baltimore Museum of Art just opened a new exhibit
curated by their own security guards.
The Week, my favorite magazine,
reports the exhibit is called Guarding The Art,
and it's up through July.
So the museum asked 17 of their security guards
that obviously are in the, you know,
building all day every day
to select works from the collection
that were important and meaningful to the security guards.
Guard, Ben Bjork, picked a chair made out of pencils
by artist Jeremy Aldeen because Ben says
he spends a lot of the day thinking about sitting down.
Well. Yeah, right?
Ross.
The fact that they got to choose, to curate a show
based on what they love just made me feel
like it was so accessible and so doable.
I felt now, that's a show I wanna go see.
So well done to this museum.
(audience applauds)
All right, we have to talk about bed times.
Think about what time you guys go to bed.
Marthastewart.com reports,
"According to a new survey to get the best sleep,
you gotta go to bed by 9:39 PM."
Survey respondents said that that
is the optimal time for excellent sleep.
And, you know, millennials, they go to bed the earliest.
What? Really?
Really?
Yeah, I didn't see that coming.
I feel like you're like a night owl, right?
I feel like the thing I struggle with with bedtime
is pretty much everything else I struggle with in my life,
is I'm such an extremist who's totally inconsistent.
I so wanna be that type A person, but I'm a hot type B mess.
Everybody who has it all scheduled out
and is hitting the sack by 9:39, I'm so happy for you.
I wish I was like you, and I'm just so not
No.
I want to be that 9:39 person.
I do.
I don't know about a set bedtime,
that seems like kinda boring.
You gotta live life a little bit.
You know what I mean?
Like for me, it just depends
on how much "90 Day Fiance" is on the DVR
when I go to bed right?
Funny enough, after the break,
we're gonna hit some more headlines and with a fresh take
from none other than one of the most
important talented comedians' comedian, Pete Holmes.
In fact, Pete-
Hi, Pete.
(audience applauds)
Hi.
Before we go to break, what is your bedtime?
Well, we have a three year old
and she goes to bed at 7:30, and we're so tired
that's when we'd like to go to bed.
But we stay up for four more hours
because if we don't, she wins.
(audience laughs)
(Ross laughs)
And you want that time to yourself.
You have to.
Otherwise, you stay up all day with her,
you're playing with her all day and then you go to bed
and then you just begin again.
I need that "90 Day Fiance" time.
Thank you.
(upbeat bright music)